I get in the Oberer nice woman normal
woman yeah normal person does not appear
at all right to be a little chunky she
looked like go always someone that could
be a relative of mine right okay
yeah nice lady decent car a nice new car
nice Chevy little car a little SUV get
in the back hey you got a charger hey
Tim I don't but if you have a cord I got
a port okay I got a cord this time I
have a cord put it in you know ten
minutes I'm just listening to some music
she tries to talk to me a few times so I
said you know what I like talking so I
just take the headphones off
and I start getting into it with her we
got I look at the the phone we got 48
minutes 48 Oh God so I seen her I'm like
hey how are you she's like good she's
like were you coming from I'm like
Austin in New York City should go you
live in New York I'm like yeah but I'm
moving here I'm gonna split time and
everything she's like oh that's cool are
you traveling on business I'm like well
I kind of live here you know my business
and personal it's kind of the same thing
she's like oh that's nice I'm like do
you live here she goes yeah I live here
I live by Englewood she goes I've been
living here six years oh that's great
she goes yeah she does I come from a
little tiny town in Florida called Perry
Florida because it's known for hunting
just a cute nice conversation and she
goes you know I had to leave she goes
because you know how small towns are you
grow up you know the same people they
know you was one thing but you want to
be other things so I'm like yeah I'm
getting into it now right like I feel
that too yeah I feel the same way as you
do she's like you know I'm I'm a
goofball I joke around but she's like
but the reality is I'm not only that I
want to do other things she's like when
I was a young kid I was an actress I
went to modeling school and she said cuz
there's you know there's there's agents
in Florida an agent Florida but it's
hard to get one in LA I'm like the
business is [ __ ] on now me I'm like
it's all over
if you don't understand you know I'm
getting going like 15 minutes may I know
what I mean I'm like I'm know what I
mean I'm in that hardcore mic thank God
I had this uber driver what a sweet
woman trying to reinvent her south ride
and you know she's talking about Florida
she's like you know I you know I was a
server in Florida I worked at the Olive
Garden like you like the Olive Garden
she's like yeah I was like I was always
a Friday's guy she goes Fridays with
always 45 minutes away you know she's
like I prefer to Applebee's this is a
small-town girl from Florida from Perry
Florida she goes I'm working about eight
or ten hours a day she cuz I met my
boyfriend here she goes when I first
moved here I didn't move in a low-income
housing I'm like I get it it's [ __ ]
it so there's a housing crisis right you
know like yeah let's go so I met my
boyfriend he was a security guard at the
building so we just started talking and
I invited him over one night to stay and
he just never left and I'm like that's
great you met someone you cared about
right she's like yeah and she goes we're
living with his mom now you know we're
looking for plays I'm like that's you
know it's okay I'm like keep her happy
she's like I do I do errands for her
whatever she needs she's like we think
we're gonna move to Vegas you know you
know because it's cheaper there and I'm
like go where it's cheap you don't want
to work she goes I can get a two-bedroom
for nine hundred like that's it's
because I can have my friends stay and
I'm like great
this is great just go listen you don't
have to be wedded to any idea of what
your life is supposed to be I'd love to
start over in a new place I don't know
anyone
I just can't because I sold my soul to
this [ __ ] you know yeah and she's like
she's like I bet you're really funny I'm
like oh I'm funny baby you know right
and she's so sweet nice jazz yeah I'm
going to because I'm working extra hard
this week because I'm going down to
Florida and I want to see my friend so I
want to make sure all my bills are paid
and I want to make sure that um I want
to make sure that I have some extra
money to spend when I go out with my
friends I said well that sounds great
and she goes I'm also gonna see my son
while I'm down there I said well that's
nice how old is he she goes he's 19 I
said 19 you know that's an age you know
what I mean yeah
I said what's he up to she goes he's
Gettys in a little bit of trouble I'm
like well night team you know how they
are yeah when I was 19 I was a hooligan
I was smoking weed running around not
paying my bills licenses suspended I get
it what's going on with him smoke a
little weed get a little crazy not in
school doesn't know what he wants to do
she goes yeah he's incarcerated right
now he's incarcerated right now and in
the county jail he's been there about a
year was it drugs she goes well he just
fell in with the wrong people and I said
that's always the way it's so hard right
you can do now thinking about you know
she's talking about getting an apartment
for nine hundred and hagas I'm like well
things are percolating but she's so
sweet
yeah I'm like let's just a sweetie this
is a woman who she had a kid young it's
very hard the [ __ ] life is tough yeah
I'd look at the I look at the phone we
got about we got 21 minutes left we're
in the final stretch so I said I said
we're we're talking and she goes you
know he's incarcerated and my mother
visits him every other week his father
never wanted to be a father so he
doesn't really visit him and I go yeah
you know I said it's tough I miss what's
he in there was it like a fight drugs or
something the car goes silent I go I'm
not comfortable amount of silence she
goes rape it's a rape and I go I now
trying because we've had this very
positive conversation about life
affirming and moving and changing and
evolving yeah so I said oh she goes yeah
but she goes three of the girls they
already say their testimonies are
inadmissible but they're going with the
other two I said three of three of the
women she goes yeah because one of them
said he did it with a knife and that's
not Justin Justin wouldn't do that
Justin wouldn't put a knife to someone's
throat and now I'm in the Oberer and
we're talking about the Olive Garden
five minutes ago
we're talking about her getting an
apartment in Vegas and how nice it was
she wanted to have
of an explorer who was in LA yeah and
I'm like so your son is a serial rapist
at 19 and he's been in jail for a year
in Florida she goes well he's got a
public defender and she goes she goes
you know women lie and I go I bet some
do I bet some do I bet some and now I'm
like am I on a show and I on some type
of thing where I'm gonna be [ __ ] now so
I'm trying to make very cautious
statements I'm like well human beings
are you know they're prone to you know I
mean it's yeah because some of these
these these girls are lying okay so so
go and she goes just gonna be trial soon
I said oh okay and she goes but he's in
Polk County in Polk County Polk County
uh you know it takes a while she goes
but she goes here's what I think
happened she goes he had sex with two
girls and then she cuz I think they felt
bad about it afterwards and then they
went and said that it was rape but it
was a you know she goes it sounds like a
threesome to me so I said well I mean
you know I'm like oh why did why not at
the headphones in and I'm like I thought
it would be if it was our time just put
my headphones right in and just but I'm
like I'm in now I can't get out so I'm
like I don't know what to say to that I
go well you know I mean he's in jail for
a year like that sounds that sounds like
there might be something to it yeah you
know I mean again I'm not a law
enforcement person yeah but he's in jail
for a year she goes you know they really
drag their feet over there and they only
let them out for an hour a day and I'm
like okay so we finally pull up to the
house and I go well listen I hope it
works out she goes yeah she goes
listen Vegas is cheap I'm like well the
other mother I mean I know that you've
moved on from your son that I'm still
invested because I just met him ten
minutes ago and I hope that this works
out and she does I should have I should
have had to move to LA with me she goes
but he's he's anxious he has anxiety
like okay
so Timmy gets his body sass and Timmy
goes on the Google's I said let me go on
the Google I said I wonder if I'll be
able to find this guy I said I wonder if
I'll be able to find this gentleman yeah
say somewhere in ok I said maybe I won't
you know I'm just gonna Google Polk
County rapist let us see what I okay
okay okay
Polk County deputies say they've
arrested an 18 year old serial molester
who's accused of raping and molesting
girls aged 12 to 15 12 to 15 to 12 year
olds to 13 year olds in a 15 year old
his arrest affidavit say snuck into the
girl's bedroom windows pinned one down
in a park threaten one with a knife and
threatened to take matters into his own
hands if a victim refused to meet him it
sounds like a threesome it's cheaper in
Vegas you needed to leave a small town
because you wanted to grow as a purse
[Laughter]
your son is a serial molester who's
raping people at gunpoint and you're
talking about you're doing [ __ ]
[ __ ] motivational [ __ ] self-help
book [ __ ] in the car she did tell me
before I got out she goes you know he
was touched on his father's side that's
why I always tried to keep him away from
his father's side so this poor guy and I
don't mean that because he's a demon but
he was probably [ __ ] and now he's raping
him letting people but dude you got to
remember where this conversation started
her telling me I left that small town in
Florida cuz I just wanted to realize my
dreams yeah and maybe my dreams aren't a
career maybe I'll never be a great
actress but you know what I can really
challenge myself and discover who I want
your son is a serial rapist who's raping
children and you telling me that you
want to go and do [ __ ] I want to go
back to school for cosmetics I want to
work on set because I want to work on
set - and makeup we lurch because I took
a summer course we learned a lot of
stuff special effects everything was
really cool huh
your son is holding knives to children's
throats in Florida and you're talking
about makeup that you want to be unset
because I want to do men's grooming on
set I'm like I don't what is that even a
anyway let's get back to your rapist son
who's terrorizing a community and I read
more about him supposedly he hangs out
outside of the middle school the
sheriff's like this guy's a terrifying
dangerous member of the community who
needs to be like lock and key
right and she's like he's was on
probation for touching a kid before yeah
he got arrested for this and she's like
I'm just tired of the small-town vibe
she's like you know people in the small
town they just they never see it for
what you can become I'm like this was a
very sweet conversation until we brought
up your son who's raping everybody in
Florida holy [ __ ] one over eyebrow one
over one who bride and I started I took
my headphones as I started to talk to
her I'm like man [ __ ] all these people
that don't want to talk to their uber
drivers it's not right right these are
people you should talk to them they have
stories I'm a comedian I'm a podcaster I
I thrive on stories and I was right but
I was like why would anyone want to put
their headphones in and not speak to
another human being in the car yeah
thirty minutes later we're talking about
this guy and I'm like where where so I'm
like you've been here six years he's 18
six years ago he was what twelve the dad
doesn't want to be a dad where are you
is he with your mom yeah you're out here
taking makeup courses while these kids
running around in and out of mental
institutions
right this is what she said she's like
he's been in a lot of institutions I was
dude I was like [ __ ] it's insane it
was crazy it's like a Florida Project
mom yeah I felt like it was kind of
surreal yeah because she was so detached
and the front part of that conversation
was so different right and right after
she drop me off I guarantee she picked
somebody else and she's like yeah we're
thinking of going to Vegas we're just
going to Vegas I hope that's how every
override she does starts it's just a
little cheaper we just want to save
money we just need each other
right we just want to love each other it
doesn't matter that I didn't make it as
an actress
I like doing makeup I like people and I
bet it for most people it doesn't get to
my son held a knife to a 12 year olds
throat right and I had to leave Florida
god